c'est peut-être pas très malin de sa
part d'avoir dit ça parce que c'est un
petit peu de la provocation mais d'un
autre côté on peut peut-être pensé qu'
il n'a pas totalement tort
dans la mesure où maintenant ça va
bientôt faire trois semaines qu'on est
confiné et que
du coup oui les personnes qui sont en
réanimation en ce moment ça veut dire
qu'elles ont peut-être été contaminées
dans les deux dernières semaines le
virus il était déjà là donc c'est des
personnes qui étaient là afrique était
au mauvais endroit au mauvais moment au
mauvais endroit donc dur que les
personnes qui fait qu'ils ont pas
respecté le confinement
c'est dû à ça je pense pas quand même
c'est un peu trop c'est un peu ce qu'ont
tiré par les cheveux
je pense que surtout les personnes qui
sont en réanimation ce sont les
personnes qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'avoir deux vasques notamment à cause
de la pénurie mal gérée par le
gouvernement je trouve que c'est un
absurde comme réflexion
il ya beaucoup de gens malheureusement
qui semble vouloir ont été contaminés et
qui se retrouvent au réanimation donc
c'est pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
respectées logiquement